Let us demonstrate
the fundamentals
of the approach that is called
integer optimization that
is used in the eHarmony
matching algorithm.
Suppose we have three
men and three women.
Their compatibility scores range
between 1 and 5 for all pairs,
and they are shown
in the figure.
For example, the first
man and the first woman
have a compatibility score of 1.
The first man and
the second woman
have a compatibility
score of 3, and so forth.
So how should we
match pairs together
to maximize compatibility?
The red line indicates a match.
In this case man one is
matched to the third woman
with a compatibility score of 5.
The second man to
the first woman
with a compatibility score of 4.
And the third man to the second
woman with a compatibility
score of 5.
And a total compatibility
score of 14.
Let us now formulate
this matching problem
in the language of
integer optimization.
We denote the data for the
matching problem as w_ij.
These numbers represent
the compatibility score
between user i and user j.
In the example shown in
the figure, w_13 is 5.
We first define
decision variables x_ij.
These are binary
variables taking
value 1 if we match user i and
user j together, and value 0
otherwise.
We next define the
objective function,
which is to maximize
compatibility between matches.
In this case, we maximize
the sum of (w_11*x_11) +
(w_12*x_12) and so
forth, up to (w_33*x_33).
We next define the constraints
for the decision variables
x_ij.
Each man-- say, man one --should
match to exactly one woman.
And we represent this by
the mathematical constraint
as follows-- x_11
+ x_12 + x_13 = 1.
Similarly, each
woman-- say, woman one
--should match to
exactly one man.
And we represent this
constraint mathematically
as x_11 + x_21 + x_31 = 1.
The full optimization
problem is indicated next.
First we have the objective
function we indicated earlier.
Next we have the
set of constraints
that indicate that every man
should match with exactly one
woman.
Next we have the
constraints that every woman
should match with one man.
And finally that the
variables are binary.
Let us now extend the
methodology to other areas.
Suppose, for example, we want
to show each woman her top two
matches.
This is represented
by the constraint x_11
+ x_21 + x_31 = 2.